[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من قوه الانفجار انا يعني ما عاد يعني
اسمع شي غير اسمع في شي صغير بس بس حسيت
حالي اني انا بالارض
بس معرفه شو اللي راح يعني صراحه فلما
شالوني حسيت انه انا هون خسرت رجلي اليسار
والله يعني هيك سبحان الله رب العالمين
اعطاني قوه بهذاك الوقت اني ضب رجلي بايدي
يعني
شيل رجلي انا بايدي
وشالوني ونزلوني واخذوني على
على المشفى ما كنت مستوعبه شو اللي صار
يعني بهذاك الوقت بس بنفس الوقت
احس هو فظيعه يعني حس هو بحياتي ما حسيته
صراحه
[موسيقى]
حرفيا انا سمعتها قالوا ياريت ميته اريح
من هالعيشه اللي هي راح تعيشها
فهونه صراحه بلش المشوار وبلشت استوعب
وبلشت
خليني مش راح اقول اندمج مع المحيط بس
بنفس الوقت
اتقبل اكثر الشي اللي انا صار معي
وحرفيا انا بعد ما طلعت من المشفى متل ما
قلت لك شهر وطلعت على لبنان
[موسيقى]
هونيك كمان بلشت مسيره ثانيه صراحه
تقريبا بعد كم شهر خليني اقول سته لسبع
شهور
حصلت على اول طرف وكان طرف عادي كثير
صراحه
من الميكانيك تبع الركبه
والطرف التجميلي اللي بيجي بس كنت مبسوطه
اول ما حطيت الطرف ما بعرف اوصف هاي
اللحظه بس مثل كاني واحد هيك طاير فوق
السماء
[موسيقى]
انت تركدي 21 كيلو متر على طرف رياضي او
خليني اقول على طرف صناعي بشكل عام
هاي بالنسبه لالنا صراحه
يعني نوعا ما رحت يعني صعب كانت وانت
تستخدمي طرف صناعي تركدي هاي المسافه او
تمشي هاي المسافه يعني
ما راح يكون في شراء يعني ما راح يكون سهل
لانه راح
حطي ضغط عليك وضغط على البتر عندك يعني
وهذا لا سمح الله ممكن يسبب لاشياء ثانيه
بس بنفس الوقت كان هدفي هذا الشي يعني انا
صحيح بحب الركض بس انه نوعا ما استفيد
وخلي العالم تستفيد من هذا الشيء من خلال
الشيء اللي انا عملته
بالنسبه لالي هي لما حققتلها في مره ثور
بصراحه مثل ما قلت لك حكيت لك الشعور كان
كتير عظيم بس بنفس الوقت ما كنت عم بعرف
اعبر لما عملت التنكيس السنه الماضيه كمان
بنفس الوقت
كمان كان شعور يعني الحمد لله رب العالمين
شعور كاني هيك بالانتصار على حالي قبل قبل
الشي اللي انا او رساله يلي عم حامل وصلها
للمجتمع
ان يكون ضمن 100 امراه
البي بي سي
البريطانيه اللي اختارتني كمان هذا انجاز
كتير عظيم بالنسبه لالي متل ما قلت لك انك
تنقلي سوره المراه العربيه لالهن وتكون
يضمن هذول الناس ياللي عن جد كانوا حول
العالم كلهم ومن فتره كمان
الشهر الماضي الحمد لله رب العالمين بفضل
رب العالمين
وصلت على جائزه المراه العربيه
بشكل عام هيك
انجازاتي عن جد يلي انا ممكن لولا
الامتحان اللي رب العالمين امتحني فيه
والشغل والتعب يلي اكيد تعبته واشتغلت على
حالي لحتى وصلت لهون
يعني اكيد ما كنت حققتها والانجازات
والفضل رب العالمين وفضل اهلي والناس اللي
بيحبوني
[موسيقى]
شكرا لانك صبرتي
شكرا لانك اشتغلتي على حالك كثير
شكرا لانك ما سمعتي للانتقادات للافكار
السلبيه يلي كانت تجيكي
وانا فخوره فيك عن جد الشي اللي وصلتي له
ويلي راح توصلي باذن رب العالمين لو كان
انجاز كتير بسيط بالنسبه لغيرك هو انجاز
كثير عظيم لانه الشي اللي مرت فيه
صعوبات وخليهم يقول
والاضطرابات النفسيه والجسديه هي اللي
صارت ما كانت قليله
والتحديات اللي مروا بحياتها ما كان شي
سهل على اي حدا
فانا فخوره فيك
وهيك ان شاء الله منحقق انجازات اكثر باذن
رب العالمين